as you as you move forward I think and I
have to understand this I know our
coaches understand this and I think our
team understands this that some of these
situations hell they're new for me you
know I understand that but I also
understand I'll get better from them and
I understand our team will get better
from them our team hasn't been in that
situation before so our team will get
better the next time that arises will be
better because of it and the thing I
want to stress to everyone is we're
building this thing that's Freddie
kitchens the Browns head coach after
Sunday night's loss to the Rams he then
was back with the media on Monday
explaining his decision to not run the
ball once when the Browns had the ball
first and goal down 7 with less than a
minute to play and all three timeouts
and Chris I I talked about this on the
radio side I don't know that a press
conference is the moment to share your
inner monologue about what you may be
feeling as you get used to a job that
maybe you're not fully qualified for and
you're learning it on the fly I don't
know that you want to broadcast that to
the world this is new to me
I don't think that inspires the
confidence in the fan base that you're
looking for because first of all the
guy's been coaching football most of his
life right right and this isn't all that
difficult of a decision you get the ball
first and goal it's it's the game is
laser-focused at that point here's what
it comes down to can you score from the
six with four cracks at the end zone
where time isn't a factor because you've
got three timeouts go and and I I don't
know that the I'm new at this excuse is
good enough and even if it is good
enough I don't know that it's something
you want to tell the world well yeah I
mean I get it it's not the best look but
the big thing is is it's not an excuse
and that's where I can get behind it and
go no this is an excuse this is this is
like a real answer he's peeling back the
curtain a little bit I respect him for
that it's not like I don't look at this
and go oh this is horrible this is BS
like I do with Bruce Arians who changes
his his talking point from a Sunday to a
Monday and I know we'll get to that
later in the show but I think yes Freddy
kitchens you know is it the best time to
be honest maybe
not but I think also guys on the team
and and people can rally around this to
a degree I don't want to say rally
around it but can accept it because he
is new okay and yeah maybe he did get
the job a little bit before he was
supposed to but we know why he did get
the job and he is there and he is kind
of learning on the fly and he's
admitting he made a mistake and it's
he's trying to take some of the blame
off the players too by saying I could
approach and help the players out too
and and I respect that but why not just
simply say look in that moment that was
the decision I thought was the right
decision I decided to keep the ball in
Baker Mayfield hands and if he saw an
opening he always has the freedom to run
in but there wasn't one there but we
only had four opportunities yeah if you
run the ball are you gonna score on the
running play you're just gonna tighten
everything up even more at least from
the four or five yard line you've got a
little space to work your receivers
through I I just think that that I know
that a big part of being a head coach is
the ability to sit there and give
answers that the media will accept and
the fans will embrace and if I'm a
Browns fan I don't know that I'm
embracing cut me some slack I'm new at
this I you you were hired above anyone
else who could have been hired and there
were plenty of candidates out there that
and and to get that job you know once
you get I made this point earlier you
give somebody a promotion in any other
workplace and you give them the
promotion because you're believing they
can do the job and so it's time to do
the job and if you don't get the job
done you don't say well I'm new at this
well you who cares do given this job
because you're expected to be able to do
the job and in a highly competitive
field like professional football where
there are many a candidates out there
that would have wanted that job and
worked with Baker Mayfield you can't
play the I'm new at this card and I
don't buy that I'm new at this card he
called plays all last year Chris after
the firing a few Jackson and Todd Haley
okay yeah it still doesn't mean he's
just like a greased well-oiled machine
and he's just like Sean McVeigh or Kyle
Shanahan or Josh McDaniels yet you know
he's not perfect and we have oh did we
ever have a moment with Sean McVeigh
were like man he's new at this or did he
just jump right in and hit the ground
running and off he goes and that's why
he's one of the great coaches in the NFL
oh yeah he had a team that was awesome
he had a defensive coordinator he didn't
have to worry about on that side of the
ball okay yeah you know he's not Sean
McVeigh he's not you know and again you
know we know why Freddie kitchens got
the job so you can't let's not blame
Freddie kitchens he got the job because
Baker Mayfield like them and Cleveland
knew if they lost him and he went
somewhere else and had another great
year as an offensive coordinator he'd be
a head coach somewhere has like an
offensive quarterback whisperer type guy
and then Cleveland would have it thrown
in their face so this is a little bit of
the politics of the NFL but you know
could he have answered it a little more
politically correct to where yes he
doesn't give you know an avenue of
talking points from talking heads like
you and I yeah sure but he also didn't
want to give their you know shove BS
down our throats with oh you know this
is what I had and this is what I wanted
to do when you made the point there was
timeouts
he knows that too so he's just hiding to
kind of say yeah I messed up I messed up
a little bit he should like my plan of
attack and I like these plays but I
think he should have said I could have
thought about a different approach and
if he really was being candid and honest
and direct that that this is his inner
monologue that he's sharing with us that
I'm new at this I don't know that that's
the right level of confidence either I
think he needs to be telling himself
don't second-guess yourself you made the
decisions that you thought were the
right decisions in the moment I guess
that's my big takeaway here is I don't
think this is something you get better
at with time you either have the
instinct on when to call the right plays
at the right moments and how to make the
ball get from outside of the goal line
inside of the goal line you either have
that or you don't I don't think it's
something you learn with experience
am I wrong on that you are I do think
you're wrong on that because they are
human beings and they get caught up in
the emotions on the sidelines at times
and they lose track of you know maybe
the big picture at at time so where yeah
they do learn I mean I can I just
remember you know so many meetings on a
Monday even with Jon Gruden who was like
yeah that wasn't the best by me I'm
gonna learn from that and
approach that differently next time you
know it's new you say that at the press
conference so he did not and I get that
I I know what you're saying and and yes
so there's there a better way Freddie
kitchens could've explained that
certainly okay but after the guy they
had their last year the press
conferences are still way better and the
offense is way better and the team's way
better and yes it's not perfect and
they're all working progress in
Cleveland right now and that's why it
was critical for guys like Freddie
kitchens to work harder to get the bar
lower the bar should not be playoffs for
the Browns it is something that is going
to take some time and the explanation
from kitchens yesterday underscores that
all right the new Browns coach a work in
progress the old Browns coach ie the
Ravens coach a guy who's been around for
a while maybe a work in progress when it
comes to analytics John Harbaugh getting
criticized for going for it on fourth
down
going for two excessively he stood by on
Monday a decision to go 4-2 after a
touchdown that put the Ravens behind by
11 points against the Chiefs on Sunday
here's what John Harbaugh had to say
getting it to 9 gives you a much better
chance of winning than taking into
overtime and you still have a chance to
do that with a second two and if for
some reason they happen to kick a field
goal score touchdown it also enhances
your odds so while you may think any
attends the thing to do it's the thing
to do if you want to go into overtime
it's not the thing to do if you want to
win the game in regulation and that's
what we were trying to do I kind of
understand that a little bit because I
know it's become popular when down 14 to
go ahead and go for two and and and put
it on a spot where you're down six and
seven wins the game it's a little more
convoluted to buy into that with this
concept of being down 11 so let's go
ahead and make it 9 so a touchdown and a
field goal will win it for us I mean
this is a point where you're you're too
far removed from leading the game to
play that that chess match you know I
can understand it we're down 14 we
scored a touchdown let's go for 2 we'll
be down 6 a touchdown wins this idea of
well let's go for two more down 11
because then a touchdown in the field we
hear you're asking for a lot there you
still got to get the touchdown in the
field goal before any of this is
relevant well yeah I mean it's the whole
day
you know that I don't understand I mean
the Baltimore Ravens tried to play the
Kansas City Chiefs game they tried to
out Kansas City Kansas City in Kansas
City and that ain't gonna happen I I
don't get it it's like they came out in
the game and were like no we're gonna
show we're the greatest offense in
football and we're gonna throw the ball
on the rail it's six nothing the hell
was seven nothing we're gonna make it
eight nothing we're gonna do I mean
where did this come from they didn't go
for two in the first two weeks of the
year you know what you know I just don't
understand it and I understand being
aggressive to it to a degree you're
playing the Kansas City Chiefs and their
offense and all of that but you know I
just don't think Baltimore is built to
be in shootouts quite yet Baltimore
their bread and butter is running the
football and I thought in the first half
of the game they got away from that they
start the second half they've run the
ball every play and they smash it right
down Kansas City's face and go down and
score a touchdown so I really think they
got a little into leg you know for lack
of a better phrase reading their press
clippings about how explosive they were
and I want to say no your Baltimore run
the ball play defense make the game ugly
I mean you know as much as we want to
save talked about that two-point
conversion they had two miracles to make
that game look respectable or that game
would have been an absolute blowout it
was a fourth and five chuck it up in the
air I hope my guy catches it a third and
17 throw it across the whole frickin
field hope my guy catches it that caught
it and they caught it and led two points
or that games gonna be a disaster
Baltimore and some of the decisions they
made I felt like let the game get out of
hand and played right into the Chiefs
hands III really think the simplest
explanation for what happened on Sunday
from the Ravens was back when the
schedule came out they circled week
three at Kansas City this is our chance
to go show off our offense which is
better than their offense we're going to
show it off every chance we get fourth
down go four - this isn't about
analytics this isn't about chasing
points this is about showing off Lamar
Jackson in our offense and proving to
everyone that our all offense is better
than the Chiefs say they didn't mike
underlined they tried and they didn't at
the end of the first half they did they
threw the ball every play and then you
know what happened they didn't get a
first down they gave Kansas City the
ball back with a minute and 18 seconds
left Kansas City went down I got a
before the half you know just things
like that where you go man that's not
like Baltimore I'm the biggest fan of
John Harbaugh I think he is the freakin
man I just think this is one yeah they
went little like you're saying overboard
aggressive
- maybe prove a point to themselves and
instead of just trying to win the
football game
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports